[Music]
in body-image plates news submitted by
Anne's Pretzels Macy's removes plates
from its stores over accusations that
they promote eating disorders plates
like dinner plates small plates Park
this story is crazy
Oh 45 plates for a gym
they call this a dinner plate and that
promotes an eating disorder point Oh
like the desert just wait okay let's
hear about this one they'd like to get
something maybe there's a hole in the
plate yeah
there's no plates it's just it's just a
box of air [ __ ] JK news isn't about
facts it's about assumptions okay pretty
much and so accurate we love to
Detective us yeah yeah so this comedian
and podcast host named Allie ward
tweeted out how can I get these plates
from at Macy's banned in all 50 states
this is what they look like they're
portion control plates
oh really pisses me off like like mom
jeans with the biggest portion favorite
jeans in the middle and skinny jeans is
the smallest and this other plate says
food coma for the biggest and foodie for
the smallest that plate really pisses me
off like a hilarious person that started
this as a comedian right yeah so this
has probably meant to be a joke that
turned real so she you know the
comedians on commenting it's made by
Macy's the person who spread the picture
no they're like I don't know like the
comedian saw this at Macy's yeah and she
took a picture of it tweeted it out yeah
just one commenting on it yeah so she
tweeted this out can I get Macy's to ban
this right oh you think she's serious so
it sounds like she would be serious I
think she's serious - why don't we tease
one ban [ __ ] now on cuz you're not real
comedian how is your comedian then
because I think the joke here is to send
that out and be like that's funny
well maybe the comedians the title so
this woman saw this at Macy's and didn't
like it sounds more like an activist to
me yeah that's well that's that's the
current get your comment on this was
quote my call for a nationwide ban was
hyperbolic but I do think that anyone
casually sees these can experience body
shame and I think it sends a really
warped message to women specifically
about starvation as well as having no
grasp on portion size and healthy eating
choices veggies take up way more room
than mac and cheese so this doesn't even
help anyone have a healthier
relationship to intuitive eating
she got all of that from the squiggly
cursive font yeah let's see what she
looks like and it's also catered to
specifically women it's like it's not
like in a diet section you know what I
mean yeah it could be like a phony
baloney like a dietician or whatever but
is mom so mom jeans that's an actual
like fit yeah like dad jeans yeah no no
monkeys are not an actual it's not a
it's not like a dad hat where it's
already existing you know I know guys
who wear skinny jeans and mom jeans
it's unfortunate how okay what is it
what a mom jeans for guys look like
high-waisted jeans
those are dad jeans oh the daddies yeah
our they're high-waisted jeans but well
some guys just look like moms and um I
guess you know how like some girls
shirts right they have the boyfriend
shirt it's supposed to look like you're
wearing like a guy's shirt so it's a cut
it's the name of a cut yeah this is nice
so mom jeans are a cut okay
it just means fat people jeans it means
like when you're wearing like
high-waisted you can eat more so it's
like Oh cover up your belly with your I
mean this is speaking from experience
cuz I love high-waisted pants cuz they
tuck me in mm-hmm and so mom jeans are
like a word for high-waisted pants that
back you look like a mom or like baggy
like I said it's still high-waisted but
the mom jeans are the comfortable jeans
that you can do you could watch kids in
you could clean the house in they're not
very flattering loser
they're loose yeah they're more boxy so
it's not good to have a reminder to
coordinate your dinner size with what
you want to wear Lee making money off of
women struggling to figure out how much
to eat yeah cuz this is this is like
clearly geared towards women only women
are people do a massive double ramekin
do people who sell books about eating
disorders
profit
off of people with people yeah I kind of
had a coconut is like because that's a
how - how - I guess control your I'm not
condoning or disagreeing or what or or
degree I'm just saying like isn't that
kind of like a how-to book like it's a
how-to when I do - ha when I think of
stuff when it comes to diet and all that
[ __ ] like I don't think Macy's I want to
go to Macy's and find that that's why
I'm shocked that people aren't taking
this as a joke because know who really
uses that plate as a portion control I
thought that was a major company me yeah
you must know like they actually make
dinnerware your portions like they had
like a wine glass that says I like they
kind of make little jokes on the
portions
I forgot that so it's a joke right it's
a gag it's more than the light-hearted
end of it but so the company themselves
so okay is the company making these
products saying that if you use these
portion controls it'll help you in your
diet or is it like a joke like okay they
said as the creators of portions we feel
badly if what was meant to be a
light-hearted take on the important
issue of portion control was hurtful to
anyone portions is intended to support
healthy eating and drinking everyone who
has appreciated portions know that it
can be tough sometimes to be as mindful
and moderate in our eating and drinking
as we'd liked but it Jen as we'd like a
but a gentle reminder can make a
difference that was what that's all we
ever meant to encourage I think they are
supporting they support intent is just
dangerous this is the skinniest the
skinny jeans it's like this big it's a
very small portion imagine if it's like
oh this girl's like well I have a salad
you know the vegetable thing it's like
okay well I can only eat that's like
could encourage in the wrong developed
mind starvation like that's a very small
portion ok yes if it's like one donut
could fit in that circle yes but if like
you're a girl who's trying to like
that's put food on her plate and she's
like [ __ ] I can only put this chicken
breast in that little circle I can't
have anything else that's like not
enough food I can see it going that way
but also as a fitness coach
sometimes I'll tell people all you
should stay under 70 grams of fat or fat
or under 200 grams of carbs or whatever
they God what does that mean I'm like a
handful size of rice a palm size of
whatever so and they go okay now I know
what to do so to me that's kind of cool
because they're taking something that is
already common I guess fitness dietary
lingo and just making it the actual palm
size the positive aspect of portion
plate which is like this so they have
like and there's no cursive it's not
yeah this is the accurate way of doing
what you're doing it's not geared to
just women
exactly there's a difference between
being healthy and being skinny so to be
like skinny jeans is this portion you be
skinny and unhealthy yeah yeah but
there's also like don't buy the plates
you know I mean like like people can
decide what they think in the
marketplace they can decide oh I think
this is like you can't just decide to be
bulimic or anorexic like eating
disorders aren't a choice but in this
order are norms and looking at a plate
either do you no no no no yeah of course
not there's born just deep psychological
issues you if you think it's like
looking at a [ __ ] plane is gonna
create an eating disorder like that's
not what's going on man like that's it
the most simplistic like way to look at
an eating disorder like that I've ever
heard is like oh I looked at this plate
and now I have any eating disorder I
feel like if you're a woman you're what
you're shopping or your teenager and you
see this you're like oh [ __ ] oh god even
if I don't buy this plate I just saw
what a traditional to be able to fit
into skinny jeans this is the portion
size I need now that's ingrained in my
bread in my mind in high school I used
to eat an orange for lunch it pays not
where did I learn that right now they're
not like we have terribly pick up on
things you don't even know you're
picking up on yeah yeah right so you're
saying it's a pattern of things like so
you pick up like you it's the plate it's
the cup it's the dish it's the the art I
see that see things i watch on TV
I think it's culturally that [ __ ] yeah
like if anything but but maybe what
you're saying is that if you stack it
all together it wrecks that I mean it's
the I think it's the lack of education
because first of all when I looked at
the plates I thought it was a big joke
because I forgot that I have
years of knowledge of nutrition and
stuff like that that's like oh that's
right so okay if you knew that before
then you look at that you go oh it's a
stupid joke but if I didn't know I might
actually use this as a as a measurement
portion like but instead of looking at
it as like oh this isn't real it's just
funny to like you know have like less
and now I'm a skinny jeans person or
whatever then it's not the creators of
it it's not a joke like it's not a funny
thing the way you're looking at it for
them they're like we're trying to help
people with portions like that's how
they viewed it but to add to yours um
[ __ ] I lost my thought go ahead I think
also the comedian chick is also kind of
just policing where her bias is that
because I don't think there's anything
wrong with people wanting to wear mommy
jeans so I don't think there's anything
wrong skinny jeans or mommy jeans so
like let's say you are a skinny jeans
person right and like let's say you want
to fill out then you maybe should be
eating mommy Jean sized portions so you
can fill out your mommy but girls don't
normally go I can't wait to wear mommy
jeans cuz it's not it's about that's
their own bias is that they already have
their right or wrong in their mind I'm
just saying you could be a hundred
pounds you could be one whatever you
want 190 deciding the pressures that
women are constantly put under that it's
been engrained in our minds where it's
like you don't want to wear baggy [ __ ]
now it's becoming a trend I wear a lot
of baggy [ __ ] a lot of baggy pants and
pants that look like mommy jeans but
it's not for the masses
I look that women are striving to go for
me they should be I guess like blamed
for it if if it's the own people's
personal negative bias it's not but it's
just it's just a step slippery slope
well you think it's like art right like
like if if you look at something and I
look at something we're gonna two
different interpretations based on our
experience is all I kind of [ __ ] so when
Joe looks at this plate he thinks it's
funny when people with it he needs to
sort of look at this plate there go oh
my god so it's just it just depends on
where you're at now but the but the
intent is what I think is so important
right the company means this but then
maybe everyone's like will [ __ ] you I
think this and I think both are okay not
necessarily
don't look at it and you you have an
eating disorder so now you're triggered
by these plates I think it's just this
idea of like we're up watching rom-coms
or Disney movie it's where the princess
is saved by the man and this has been
grieved in my head from a very small
from a very young age so imagine if
these place were super mainstream and
you grow up thinking like oh this is a
traditional portion size like for women
for women like it's not just affecting
people who already have eating disorders
I think it's just creating a standard
that is very dangerous I think getting
it off the shelf before it becomes like
standard in restaurants or like I don't
know I think it's just dangerous and
constantly reinforces the bad things
yeah so obesity is a pretty bad thing
that's going on in the states right now
we are over eating right and like what
if this company is just trying to do a
fun little take on that I guess the only
thing I mean it is a big problem in the
states and we should be eating less dude
the [ __ ] serving sizes on [ __ ] is
crazy it's like this is 7 servings
weight sizes like there I saw this one
image where I was like back in like I
don't know I'm gonna make up a year but
like in the 50s 40s girl it was like
sighs like eight inch plates were
standard now it's twelve but you're
right about women all over the world
though are very ridiculed and criticized
by their for their weight and all that
and they're always told like I don't
know any country that's like you should
be fatter no no one says that no women
wants to be fatter right so that's I
don't know what part of that is just
nowadays we know like healthier is not
yeah do you guys think it'd be bad if
there was a bottle for your alcohol and
then there's like there's a bottle right
and then the first line is safe for
driving a second line is drunk driving
and that the top one is alcoholic right
like is that is there it without you
disorder by being like I'm just wanted
like Oh society says I should only have
one glass of wine now I have alcohol
disorder
it doesn't work the same way actually
with love is with someone's memories for
us lies our company so I we precise all
the time
just to figure out how many what my DAC
is after one glass of wine - glass wine
I don't drive no matter what if I'm
drinking but like that is super
educational but alcohol affects people
differently so water there's no way to
save a food though
like a ton yeah Bart's old roommate she
was a she could eat like a whole large
pizza to herself and she's like 90
pounds he's like TIFF sighs Wow
well she's smaller than TIFF yeah yeah I
know okay anyway though maybe instead
like five years ago
yeah security that in game right right
now anyways enjoy don't forget that so
tired I'm actually already tired one
thank you I appreciate that
hi Ally we appreciate you sharing this
with us and agree that we missed the
mark on this project product and we'll
be removing from all story at Macy's
locations so I just think it's
controversial to create products that
could potentially bring out people's
insecurities you're great still great
feel great enjoy your meal
that doesn't help anybody importantly
like this because they got rid of the
previous version of it when you create
products and you're trying to be funny
it's always dangerous yeah but I don't
know about taking down products or
anything you are great because you're
eating food you're still great because
you're eating foods that's right that's
the most [ __ ] current thing I've ever
heard them how about how about small
medium and large because the way I would
use not that hungry I'm not that hungry
so serve me a skinny one oh my god
that's my number one biggest like
annoyance with American restaurants is
like I wish I couldn't order a half
portion of this [ __ ] meal cuz it's
too much food to go to French
restaurants only go to Frank one of the
main arteries like this
I want that in your menu and I want the
kids menu sometimes yeah I mean kids
menus too small like a medium menu like
or give me half of the portion and
charge me half of the price because
sometimes these plates are like $25 and
I'm like just give me half of the food
that's only two or let me eat in the
dark like when we did that because I can
only eat half a night anyway so you
can't find them exactly and that's what
happened
[Music]